[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el
programa de france 24 en español en el
que analizamos el desarrollo de la
eurocopa de naciones y la copa américa
ya con las dos finales definidas estos
son los titulares del día
e inglaterra cumplió y disputará la
final de la eurocopa contra italia los
dirigidos por gareth southgate vencieron
en la prórroga a dinamarca con un
polémico penalti y fueron mejores los
británicos analizamos la controversia
arbitral
brasilia se entrena para la final de la
copa américa y argentina ya está en río
de janeiro ambas selecciones se preparan
para el partido del sábado que supone
para cada país de ganar este torneo
y analizamos el valor del partido por el
tercer puesto entre perú y colombia- ha
perdido sentido ese encuentro en un
torneo con de selecciones
inglaterra está en la final de la euro
en la final de su euro podemos decir
vamos a analizar el partido de ayer
entre en la tierra y dinamarca pero
antes como siempre saludo a sara castro
directora del de ayudas colombia hola
sara hola jugar un gusto empieza la
cuenta regresiva para dos grandes
finales así es para saber ya quiénes son
los campeones en la tierra como decíamos
eliminó en semifinales a dinamarca en el
estadio de wembley victoria 2 a 1 en la
prórroga para los dirigidos por garzón
gareth southgate con tantos de ya era en
propia puerta y harry caine para los
británicos tras un polémico penalti con
dinamarca anotó níquel a damsgaard quien
abre el marcador con un golazo el
domingo gran final entre inglaterra e
italia también en wembley será
inglaterra podemos decir que fue mejor
que dinamarca en esta semifinal sin duda
yo creo que mostró dominio solidez y lo
que salgueiro ha venido trabajando a lo
largo del torneo es un equipo sin
fisuras un equipo que si bien es
cuestionado porque solemos calificar
dependiendo de nuestro gusto
futbolístico las propuestas de los
entrenadores demostró que tiene el
temple la determinación para llevar el
equipo bajo su línea
fue mejor inglaterra en el desarrollo
del partido ahora conversaremos un poco
más sobre esa decisión arbitral que sin
duda mancha un poco toda la situación
pero en general esto responde al
proyecto inglés un proyecto inglés que
viene de trabajadores de las inferiores
desde una línea y un adn claro de lo que
quiere jugar inglaterra y sobre todo a
una generación talentosísima vimos a
sterling como siempre desequilibrante
aquel más inteligente que nunca saliendo
de su zona sacando a los centrales
entonces fue un partido interesante y
dinamarca pues jugó hasta donde pudo e
intentó con aero posición de harley que
se ha mantenido muy buen nivel durante
toda esta eurocopa efectivamente tenemos
que hablar del penalti lo hablábamos
antes es quizás la única jugada que
empaña un poco una eurocopa con casi
ninguna polémica arbitral casi ninguna
polémica arbitral y muy destacada por
otras cosas por el gran nivel físico por
los grandes planteamientos tácticos por
un nivel de estrategia muy valiente casi
siempre en todos los partidos desde los
cuartos no habíamos visto 0-0 no hemos
visto 0-0 y esto habla de la
determinación de muchos equipos de
demostrar un buen espectáculo
hubo variantes estratégicas pero siempre
lo que vimos fue buen fútbol fútbol que
busca gustar a las tribunas vimos gente
y realmente este tipo de situaciones no
se entienden y volvemos a cuestionar el
bar no por el bar en sí mismo sino
porque los árbitros siguen tomando
decisiones erradas porque o no entienden
el reglamento o no lo interpretan bien y
la tecnología no es usada de la manera
que corresponde entonces es una lástima
porque es un penal en el que no hay
contacto es decir no hay un penal y esto
mancha un poco esta situación además en
el contexto de la localidad inglesa
genera muchas suspicacias yo diría que
es un error de eso de un juez que tomó
una decisión en caliente que no quiere
ir a revisar la pantalla que es lo que
correspondía pero bueno insisto que
inglaterra es justo merecedor de estar
en la final y hablando más de dinamarca
podemos decir que si hay un pecado de
ésta dinamarca fue a ver un poco haber
esperado en la prórroga ya buscando los
penaltis desde el inicio ellos apostaron
por tres centrales muy sólidos un
mediocampo también que salía presionar
salía marcar pero que siempre estuvo en
bloque y que sí
sabía que el gasto lo tenía que ser
inglaterra no le vimos tal vez esa
versatilidad en el ataque de otros
partidos pero era entendible este tipo
de partidos se juegan con mucho miedo al
error con mucho miedo arriesgar pero le
dimos una voluntad como la de siempre lo
que ha caracterizado de una marca de
está dinamarca queda en el corazón de
todo el mundo porque nunca bajó los
brazos porque siempre buscó y hay que
hablar de dance gar no no sólo el golazo
de tiro libre ese golpeo impresionante
precioso sino también que hizo una
eurocopa tras la salida de la gran
figura de dinamarca que lo pone en la
mirada de todo el mundo hizo un torneo
de esos que cambian carreras así que
vamos a escuchar el respecto de los
penaltis que dijeron los de penalti los
entrenadores
realmente no vi la situación del final
wright pero mucha gente me ha hecho la
misma pregunta para 100 con este sistema
se digan de langreo y las estadísticas
del partido las atajadas a casas pérez
parada en cuervos game tuvo un partido
increíble tuvimos mejores ocasiones
y el penalti de lo contrario habría sido
un uno a uno puedo decir lo que hubiera
ocurrido
perdimos iniciativa en la segunda parte
pero sé que era cuestión de tiempo que
encontráramos la calma de nuevo
para cerrar ese bloque con inglaterra
finaliza qué mejor que una canción para
explicar lo que significa para los
británicos volver a una ocasión desde el
año 1996 lo hizo el grupo del aire de 7
una solución
[Música]
vamos a ver si se rompen con eso ya 50
años de dolor sin levantar un títulos de
los que habla esta canción pasamos a la
copa américa porque ahora sí ya completó
su primer entrenamiento en río de
janeiro pensando en esa final del sábado
contra argentina en el maracaná la
albiceleste está en río de janeiro
después de su victoria contra colombia
es ahora lo que vamos a analizar es qué
significa para cada selección ganar ese
torneo esta copa américa en particular
va a ser una final muy emotiva más allá
de lo que ya sabemos que representa las
dos grandes potencias del fútbol
sudamericano las condiciones
determinadas por la pandemia por la
falta de entrenamiento de los equipos
hace un buen tiempo y sobre todo porque
encontramos a dos jugadores en su máximo
nivel
estamos hablando de messi de neymar yo
diría que los encontramos el nivel de
ritmo europeo pero esto sería un
contrasentido porque justamente a ellos
los admiramos por ser contra culturales
y porque siempre recurrir a la gambeta y
a todo este tipo de recursos que nos
alegran el juego vamos a ver un duelo
además que representa mucho por
argentina por lo que significó para la
generación de messi no haber conseguido
un título teniendo lo muy cerca y
habiendo sufrido tanto esas derrotas en
los últimos años
creo que el maracaná además es el
escenario precioso para recibir una vez
este tipo de duelos desde el 2007 no se
veía esta final en la copa américa así
que bueno todo está dado además de lo
futbolístico porque creo que scaloni
también ya tienen más argumentos para
hacerle digamos un planteamiento
interesante a tite que lleva mucho más
recorrido con él
la selección muchas más variantes mucho
más trabajo vamos a ver una gran final
este sábado en maracaná y se especula ya
en la prensa con que a lo mejor hay una
pequeña presencia de público en el
maracaná y hoy hablo marquinhos el
jugador de la selección brasileña
precisamente sobre messi lo escuchamos
con un gran yoga sí es una bestia es un
jugador que puede desequilibrar un
partido así que tenemos que tomar varias
precauciones no sólo con él sino también
con los demás jugadores le tenemos un
gran respeto pero en este momento
ponemos ese respeto y admiración a un
lado
en este momento y antes de esa final de
mañana de hasta el final perdón del
sábado mañana viernes tenemos el partido
por el tercer puesto entre perú y
colombia en la eurocopa no hay partido
por el tercer puesto desde 1980 qué
valor tiene hacer un partido por el
tercer puesto en un torneo como la copa
américa que tiene 10 selecciones el
interés competitivo yo creo que ha
decaído y es evidente que debería en
algún punto tomarse esa decisión de que
no se dispute sin embargo en este en
esta copa américa sí me parece
importante
es importante porque hemos hablado de
equipos y de selecciones sudamericanas
que no han tenido el rodaje suficiente
para llegar a un interesante nivel
competitivo en las eliminatorias no hay
ningún entrenamiento no hay ningún
recurso que reemplace la competencia es
decir que para reinaldo rueda ricardo
gareca tener este partido va a ser una
prueba adicional y vamos a ver si
apuestan por poner fichas que no han
usado por ejemplo reinaldo rueda tiene
defensas que no aprovechado va a tener
hoy en rueda de prensa óscar murillo eso
puedes darnos un indicio y por el lado
de gareca lo mismo o si ya se van con un
equipo consolidado que sea la base para
afrontar las eliminatorias desde el
punto de vista competitivo a mí me sigue
pareciendo importante que los equipos
tengan unidades de trabajo y son dos
días adicionales ahora ninguno puede
perderlo de mala manera no porque ese
tercer puesto que parece poco importante
empieza a cobrar relevancia en el
momento en que el equipo empieza a
demostrar sus formas y las maneras del
trabajo realizado es decir el que gane
podrá decir bueno caemos en semifinales
pero nos llevamos está medallista de
bronce por decirlo así si yo creo que
más allá del título de lo que represente
esa medalla
creo que los técnicos están pensando más
en aprovechar estos días de convivencia
en hacer un balance en cerrarlo cerrarlo
de buena manera y ojalá puedan probar
alguna que otra variante o por lo menos
que alguno de estos jugadores tenga la
posibilidad de tener minutos en
selección que ya también hace toda la
diferencia seguramente veremos muchas
variantes en este partido por el tercer
puesto recordamos viernes partido por el
tercer puesto y ya el sábado en la final
hay más noticias de esta recta final de
la copa américa y la eurocopa empezamos
hablando del torneo de sudamericano
porque el uruguayo esteban nuestro hit
será el árbitro principal del al final
de este sábado entre argentina y brasil-
colegiado estuvo al frente del encuentro
inaugural entre brasil y venezuela y
también en el duelo entre perú y
paraguay de cuartos de final su
compatriota andrés cunha será el árbitro
principal del bar
la federación rusa de fútbol destituyó
está en la serie shop como seleccionador
nacional
el técnico llevaba en el cargo desde
2016 y alcanzó los cuartos de final en
la copa mundo de 2018 en esta euro no
superó la fase de grupos y se especula
con que se busca un extranjero para
reemplazarlo
la uefa abrió un expediente
disciplinario en la tierra por la
presencia de bengalas y apuntadores
láser durante la semifinal contra
dinamarca también se investigarán los
pitidos contra el himno danés en la
antesala del partido para por cierto eso
es láser presuntamente se denuncia que
uno de ellos molestó a kasper schmeichel
durante lanzamiento penal de harry caine
para muchísimas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros un día más mañana tendremos
mucho análisis de lo que esperaremos del
juego en estas dos finales así es y como
no gracias a ustedes también por estar
con nosotros quédense porque como
siempre hay más mucho más en france24
france24 puntocom
i